vedi ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono parigi oggi siamo con
beaumarchais il buon step allora ti
hanno mai fare questo pezzo del video
maker anno devi fare lo devi fare perché
devi vedere quanta differenza c'è di
grandezza dalla casa parliamo di casa
mia casa
prego prego e poi caso suo ma tanto e
sei tu che lavori non io a posto
vinicola guarda guarda se ma il brigante
e marelli e poi se sei più megalomane di
trump che si mette la f come forma di
casa ce ne vogliamo veramente me l'ha
fatta della fata mar civili bassi e
marci pagare per ciò che libera va beh
sì infatti l'ho pagato l'ho pagato anche
profumatamente la facciamo
infatti nella vera che sorregge un anvil
la vedi di notte la vedi di notte perché
avete fatto una cosa piccolina ma roba
si onesta se si può fare un upgrade ma
questo molto più avanti metterei anche
l'occhio di sauron da qualche parte
siccome la casa è infernale ok c'è stato
l'update di minecraft dove c'è quello
strano che puoi cavalcare io lo voglio
perché fernando me la chiesa mi ha
chiesto di avere visto che adesso ci ha
preso gusto ad avere amici mi ha chiesto
compagnia quindi dovremmo andare nel
leather a prenderlo perché si intona
perfettamente col mio ma senza poi
contare che sino a fernando questo
bisogna solo fargli una pura rifilava
tutta tutta la foresta fuoco non c'è più
la foresta poi penso che sia il portale
nelle terre più bello che lo so ragazzi
ce l'abbiamo noi
l'avete visto il vincolo non era il
porto che c'è dentro portale dentro
hanno mostrato che in quella parte lì
questo l'ho fatto con bella faccia anche
con bella faccia abbiamo continuato
all'interno entra all'interno no non
quello non l'ho visto neanche in realtà
messa io ci sono e ragazzi quando entrò
ma io non ti vedo proprio ecco che il
santo iddio e la madonna ma ragazzi di
spada
ma allora ma scusa ma se tu vuoi
scrivere romanzi fallo perché non puoi
fare cioè non fare lui lo youtube
cioè se non te la faccio bello ma donne
ma neanche dante alighieri alla fatto
sta quando ha definito l'inferno sono
già morto e non sono neanche partito
trovino solo vivo a posto niente niente
tutto partito posto dove che dove siete
adesso ecco sì sì sì che la vita è
divertente
eccoci qua signor male ne andiamo adesso
cercano di capire perché c'è un
cinghiale nei led ma è nuovo e lei anche
permesso l'it ha combattuto la tua
memoria e la ragazza è preoccupata ma
infatti io potrei rifare i video come
anche quelli di un mese fa mi sta a chi
ripenseremo accensioni stryder ok ma
tutto si è bellissimo care con il tasto
destro con shift qua fa vi gira tv
catasto dei moderni con la sella che non
è la stiamo ammazzando ha messo mai
sopra ok è pazzo è pazzo è pazzo è pazzo
cosa faccio aiuto forse dove pazzo pazzo
che dovremmo farti una scala secondo me
arriva dobbiamo fare ragazzi aiuterò ma
questo ma cos'è sta roba non riesca a
webber si ferma non saranno lativo e lui
l'ha capito e se la toglie
moretti non morire l'hack è male mi fa
male è morto è morto perché ma lui va
avanti da solo se quel fungo
praticamente si ferma così adesso a
freddo e tipo tipo un parma sta tremando
ma è troppo vicino ma devono 1 in casa
nella vita ragazzi poverino ma lui
quindi può cavalcare le le le le lave
italia bellissima ma io adesso già
salendo di qua guarda c'è già tutto ciò
già sopra io so già il suo scalando ebbe
la meglio su sky
ciao a tutti per ora serve la lava più
che altro serve la lava e prevede la
lava e quanti ne hai
io non ho portato niente mi avete tutto
sella fungo io sono cavalcato sto qua è
un po lento sculetta un po però sì
quello che non muoio se vuoi entrò nella
ma sento nella navali li facciamo noi
più che altro e lui si scalda eterna
felice vedi che cambiano eccolo e poi
occorre anche l'iva andiamo come si fa
come si fa è uno che si entra così al
secondo centro di i nostri altrimenti
come si porta via ticino
ok amico mio elezioni fossero qui voglio
vedere quante più veloce è bellissimo
anche a ragazzi che abbiamo adesso bravo
ma cosa fa vj tempo di arrivare a casa
tanto ci metto se guarda guarda che la
cavalcatura più bella schifoso di uno
scheletro guarda lo guarda che scappa
perché si caga addosso guardami dai dei
micro sprint prendiamo solo tempo fa era
il lontano valori dei micro spinti fa
sul serio sono che ci mette due ore è
bellissimo
ok è infatti che tipo di curling ragazzi
soffrire davanti ma ora che la scena più
comica
ecco sto vedendo epoca arrivo e cielo
parcheggio e se ciò però io non ho fatto
niente di stupido solo tenuto il corso
grazie alla pesca vada ti vorrei di sale
ma non lo farò ma puoi farlo ecco la
casa di un precedente di fatto niente
era infatti io non faccio vincere io
però solo tasto rec non faccio niente
guarda quando anche lì monto limonta
giampiero pensa che lavoro inutile
ammira a casa tua stryder 2 3 1 set
ammirava facciamola quanto è bella mi
aveva cambiato la ride altamente nostra
lettera 17 giusto e poi l'altro mi serve
la targa è come faccio dopo avere
parlato ieri relatore grattacieli a
buddy scambiando coeli o gli anvil poi
potrò andare sull'acqua secondo voi si
fa male ora muore non so perché anche se
io sto presentimenti passo sulla no non
proviamo perché ci abbiamo messo 86 ore
ed io non torno nel caso evitando
l'acqua perché già freddo normalmente li
stavano mischiata a fernando saluto al
tuo compagno nuovo toh guarda questo è
questa la storia guarda che ti sto
portare non aveva neanche una mia banco
io ero atomico prima adesso va là che
roba mamma mia e un po mischia e non so
io faccio una bella inquadratura sulla
morte di mare vediamo da qui fai lo
screen prevale che brucia della nava
dove a domanda domanda domanda ma non è
che vidi a fuoco tutto qua no no no
shifty alla fine nell'angolino proprio
ora che c'è la quale vicina sede
no di qua non sa uscire lo si esce aia
ok ed è bene non riuscirò e come me la
metto la targhetta
a comprare al mercato a comprarla
domanda con sicuramente lo tira fuori
non si può legare no no non dovrebbe
saltare
ora che è uscito che bello e lenta che
ma non ce l'ho io ecco sono qua ne ho 55
ma sì ma perché l'avevo trovato 80mm oa
un miller o per cui mi sottopongo fatto
la rimessa pari fare questa qua o
persino io vivo sempre di sei cover lo
sai che ti ringrazio grazie sia
nazionale che va fatto un regalo grazie
grazie a tutti e due
l'abbiamo grazie mikhail tre casi fa
quindi a fare sta roba a domandare prima
prima di lei prima volta che uso lei che
è bello non mi ricordo più dove i
consumi sono anche su ok al piano
centrale nel piano centrale mila voglia
ma donna bellissima casa mia il
bellissimo che stava andando in casa mia
per fare questo ma guarda che roba
inventato allora di sopra ancora e
scusami ma tutti spendere per sempre e
che vide saranno giochetti per in casa
tua
io che mi perdi kasami avellino vorrei
anche la naturale così dai sali saline
dove stai evil ma edizione non lo trovo
a questa volta di non far vedere a massa
sulla carta di credito per forza dai
tanto minuti ruberà va bene allora
strider aspetta questo momento è in
centimetri costo ovviamente targhetta
scriverci sopra strider 23 17 e
incentivate cost online quindi devo
avere uno di exter l'atto non ce l'ho ok
damian me lo faccio io ti vedo questa
creata mentre cessato attaccano
attaccato attaccato è nata a casa però
assolutamente bene scendiamo eccolo le
cose però prima tappa sopra per forza
doveva fargli vedere quello
non so di cosa parlate vieni vieni star
di paratico
vieni vieni vieni vieni ok di qua dentro
ok a questo bellissimo
eh sì certo è quello che ti dicevo prima
ecco mi va bene bellissime che sono
sopra lo strider è uno sforzo scegliere
la caja ho mancato quel pezzo nola
borghetti nome preso ora l'ho presa a
mio avviso di decollare su ero già di
tipo no dai
eccolo io mi dissocio non bellissimo
bellissimo
non una parola è stata un bell'episodio
ragazze abbiamo trovato un nuovo amico
per fernando ma anche amico nostro
fernando continua di monassi lavoro per
un problema vero che il video vi sia
piaciuto ringrazio f march per qualsiasi
cosa o adesso ci avete anche cosa per
fissare quando entrati in casa anzi
mettere il cartello suonate la pelle
entrare suonare la campana anche se
nessuno iscrivere a calare passate anche
anche nel i marchi stefano e come sempre
ragazzi ci vediamo al prossimo video
bello ragazzi
[Musica]